Ну я за звучить на тему світ негабарема
Сергієм Шкарлатом міністром світу науки
України Пана Сергію Доброго дня вам
дня Славу
до законодавчу активності наших депутатів
Верховною Радою латиною наріжте
схвали формат річкового вступної компанії
удачі вам це щоб умовила вже ось
якусь означає йому і які-турік
цибудонаціональний мультипредметний тест
всіх побажавши містерства прослухався
депутати шимбі березнятому мульти-тест
[музика]
Сьогодні мама для всіх Мої беручі знайти
ніші сьогодні І для нас знайти нижчим з
карбон Де наші можуть бачити
компанії
та український центр
гуртки
таку послугу Я вже сказав де абсолютно
ось Женю
позицію та для бакалавські папери
[музика]
завдання
українською іспанською
Результат усі Результати будуть
і для всіх спеціальностей будуть
встановлені вагони коефіцієнти до
результату шкірного блоку ннт При всьому
вже значному Богу мінімально буде
менше
[музика]
завданням історії стає формат
хронології
історії абсолютно
ми можемо
20 20
[музика]
міністра світ це наука України на
прямому вапну